voilà pour les principales nouvelles de
l'actualité
et tu as été menu de ce samedi en
juillet je vous propose maintenant un
peu de ce qu'ils nous divertit la
culture et puis le sport la culture tout
d'abord nous étions jeudi en avignon
dans la cour d'honneur du palais des
papes pour les 40 ans du festival
mais nous allons rester dans cette même
région un peu plus bas voici le festival
photo d'arles avec un thème retenu par
jean jacques dufour et bruno carette la
mode et la photo
sublime cadre que celui du théâtre
antique d'arles surtout lorsqu'il est
servi par une magnifique rétrospective
des créations de louis féraud un
arlésien qui sait que la photographie
est à la mode
ce que le fils est à l'éguille ou vice
versa
la photo c'est un c'est un baiser sur
les joues du présent présentez-vous le
saisissent et notre mode c'est un peu la
même chose nous essayons de saisir un
moment un peu plus long mais quand on
parle de chic et comme à prévost
muschick on arrive presque à la photo
muschick inclut le mauff autour parce
que c'est un moment précis du temps
qu'on arrête ton explique aux gens
profitant de la présence des mannequins
de louis féraud j'essaie de savoir ce
qu'elle pensait de ses photographes de
mode dans le métier de fixer et de
diffuser le chic de la culture je pense
qu'ils sont un peu capricieux et parfois
capricieux que les mannequins
la maison puis est nommé chancelier
milieu il ya les bons et les très bons
les femmes est très mauvais ça vous
dérange pas si je m'en fout mal an
maintenant moi sommes deux méthodes
après le vin d'honneur
à chaud aux deux femmes de beauté et de
création louis perron s'explique je suis
impressionné par la provence et aussi
par là par l'art par l'amour qu'on a en
provence pour pour sa mère ses serres
mais considère toutes les deux comme les
cinq intouchable et lumineuse
donc toute notre passion va vers vers
cette femme que l'on veut comme sa mère
sa soeur
religieuse et lumineuse et c'est ce que
nous cherchons c'est à dire que si vous
regardez mes collections
jamais à aucun moment nous arrivons à
faire autre chose que des vêtements très
chasse l'institut de change joue
évidemment un rôle important dans les
rapports modèle photographe
mais n'allez pas imaginer que la réalité
et friponne
un rapport l'action la plupart porcu si
vous vous dit que vous n'êtes pas un
créateur de mode à sensuelle apparemment
non mais alors c'est de là à savoir
comment on va parler de la pudeur
si la pudeur n'est-elle pas elle-même
plus sensuelle que l'érotisme
je sais pas donc vous voyez à la fois
être ambigu c'est à dire chaste et
sensuelle mais je crois que c'est le
problème de tous les hommes et toutes
les femmes
geste et sensuelle la formule a fait
recette et a su séduire les spectateurs
et aussi les photographes
toujours avide d'imagés chocs ou chic